hey everyone I'm Richard and this this
is the one you've been waiting for
NVIDIA GeForce GTX 1080 the first finfet
GPU and it's fast really fast coming
back from nvidia's editor's day in
Austin Texas I thought I had a handle on
just how fast this would be 20% faster
than titanex perhaps yeah actually it's
faster a lot faster in some cases Nvidia
has delivered some strong generational
leaps across the year years and it's
done it again in fact let's start by
taking a look at performance of the
division on the old GTX 780 Ti maxed out
here at 1080p resolution now this GPU
was released in November 2013 and it was
the ultimate iteration of the Silicon
used to power the original Titan and
yeah it's still a good car today at
1080p handing in a respectable 46 FPS
average GTX 980 a smaller chip with a
newer technology launch launched 10
months later at the time it only seemed
to offer a smaller bump over GTX 780 Ti
but on Modern games like this one it's
25% faster now then Titan X the big chip
Maxwell and the true successor to the
780 Ti arrived in March 2015 and as we
add that to the graph we're 59% faster
than 780 Ti and now for the one you've
been waiting for GTX 1080 it's over
twice as fast handing in a 94 FPS a
stack up the percentages and it goes
like this on this game at least nvidia's
new card is 27% faster than Titan X it's
62% faster than GTX 980 and it
absolutely canes the 780 Ti it's 102%
faster now you might recall from
nvidia's announcement that they said
that GTX 1080 offers the performance of
two 980s in SLI well back of an envelope
calculation here across all of our
gaming tests which are still ongoing we
actually ped 1080 at around 65 to 70%
faster on average but in theory you'd
expect to see two 980s in parallel beat
the 1080 not the other way around so we
only have limited data here but it's
Illuminating this is Assassin's Creed
Unity with an i7 6700k at 4.6 GHz paired
with gtx980 in SLI and stacked up
against the GTX 1080 so you can see here
that SLI does have the advantage in fact
it's about 9% faster really but check
this out Crisis 3 on 1080 is indeed
faster than two 980s the bottom line
here is that whether 1080 is faster than
980 SLI all comes down to one factor
scalability different games scale
differently in SLI some do well some
don't in the latter case GTX 1080 will
almost always hand in better performance
but in other titles that may not be the
case as you can see with Shadow of
Mordor here now let's take a look at a
few more games moving up to 4K
resolution this time where Fury X tends
to perform best so here's the Witcher 3
maxed out at 4K but with Hair Works
turned off and we're seeing a 40 FPS
minimum on 1080 and that's a 43 FPS
average at 4K that's pretty neat here
we're 33% faster than Fury X 29% faster
than Titan X and 71% faster than 980 not
bad even a maxed out Assassin's Creed
Unity is actually playable at 4K here a
test we still include in our Rev
Benchmark Suite owing to its enormous
impact on vram and generally challenging
performance and in this extremely
testing project cars replay on Max
settings with SMA a aliasing we're
hitting a 38 FPS average here 30% faster
than Titan X and a massive 84% faster
than furri x so yeah performance on AMD
does change radically according to the
track and GPU effects so the question is
really to what extent is 1080 a game
Cher and is AMD completely off the map
now well I'd say that in some respects
they have a mountain to climb but there
are signs that nvidia's domination isn't
complete so check this out it's Hitman
maxed out at 4K running under both dx11
and dx12 yeah it's close perhaps closer
than Nvidia would like under dx11 the
1080 is only 10% faster and that drops
down to a mere 6.3% under dx12 however
rerun this comparison at 1080P and the
percentages are much more in nvidia's
favor 1080 is around 20% faster there
and of course there's ashes of the
singularity it's a game that really
works well on AMD Hardware overhauling
much of the green team's dx11 Advantage
even at lower resolutions and of course
we all know what happens with dx12 where
the fury X comprehensively outpoints
Titan X so what happens when it's
stacked up against GTX 1080 well based
on the benchmarks at 4K we see this
under dx11 GTX 1080 is 23% faster but
under dx12 that lead shrinks to just 9%
regardless though it is faster and
you'll know that dx12 performance is
pretty much on par with dx11 there's not
much in the way of the frame rate
regression that we saw with other Nvidia
cards so I think the bottom line is this
there are always games that favor one
architecture over another Hitman ashes
are the singularity well they run great
on AMD and while GTX 1080 is much much
faster than Fury X across the board you
can see titles that do favor one
architecture and these can make up some
or even a lot of the difference but the
idea that AMD is going to dominate in
future with directx12 well I think
they're well positioned certainly
compared to their dx11 performance but
there's still everything to play for and
to be frank we shouldn't really be
expecting anything in the way of
miracles in terms of dx12 performance in
the short term so check this out you've
already seen that on our test system at
least there's not a huge boost to Hitman
performance whether you're running on
dx11 or dx12 whether you're with AMD or
Nvidia and it's the same thing here with
rise of the Tomb Raider the truth is
that only certain systems will benefit
with dx12 and that doesn't seem to
include our i7 setup in fact whether
you're using AMD or Nvidia there's
actually a small drop to Performance
using dx12 so I think it's the case that
the API is definitely finding its feet
right now and dx11 is still the primary
API for PC gaming so look I've sort of
biased this review to the performance of
the GTX 1080 but there are other things
to discuss too this is the founders
Edition GTX 1080 which essentially means
it's the Nvidia reference design as I
did the testing across multiple
generations of Nvidia gpus the thing
that stood out to me was just how quiet
this thing is even under load and yet no
coil wine that I could hear either and
on top of that it's much more power
efficient too this particular particular
scene from Crisis 3 puts an insane load
on the GPU I like to use it for
overclocking stability testing but it's
also good for getting some Peak power
consumption metrics as well and here's
how the table looks only gtx980 is the
more frugal card here and obviously
that's handing in a much lower level of
performance for a very similar power dvo
and yeah that R9 390x result it really
isn't a typo so what's the bottom line
here well Titan X GTX 980 TI they were
frankly monstrous gpus and they still
are if that is a taste of GTX 1070
performance then um wow GTX 1080 is even
faster though it's the new
state-of-the-art and a frankly brilliant
piece of engineering as Ferris bu might
say if you have the means I highly
recommend picking one up but that's all
I have for you right now please like And
subscribe to support our work and don't
forget to check out those reams of
benchmarks Elsewhere on the channel and
I'll see you soon